well from holiday donuts to happy hour
pizza you and your family are invited to
the award-winning dom de marcos pizzeria
and bar the sponsors of this next
segment
[Music]
dom demarco's pizzerian bar got to go
way back to
2005.
i actually opened my first pizzeria in
1966
but in 2005 i was introduced to the
farah pizza on avenue j and east 15th
street in the midwest section of
brooklyn
and i met the pizza god dom demarco
himself
and i spent three years with him
from 2008 to 2011 making pizza with him
and i decided to come to las vegas and
open this place and name it in honor of
him so all the
pizza recipes we use here are dom
demarcos all the food recipes come from
my mother my grandmother my aunts
different people it started out with
like i said with dom demarco
he always he got all his ingredients
imported from italy
so
when i talked to him about opening here
he said you know he said everything i
use is very expensive and the reason i
never did anything with anybody is
because i didn't think that they would
use the same ingredients and i didn't
want them to ruin my reputation which i
could understand
but he realized that we were serious
about doing it his way
so it actually took me six months
to make all the connections to get all
the ingredients that come to las vegas
we're over here in the desert he's over
there in brooklyn he got everything easy
we had to go
to miami to chicago to phoenix and then
to here to get the ingredients but we
got all the ingredients and we never
change anything
and prices keep going up and up and up
and we still keep buying the best and
using his recipes we sell more pizza
than anything but we also have a huge
pasta menu
we have lasagna people love our lasagna
it's i have to say it's the best in town
so we sell a lot of salads we have great
salads a lot of pasta dishes some
fabulous desserts but our biggest seller
is pizza salads pasta and wings always
sell a hell of a lot of wings up and we
won a couple of competitions in the
wings we have great wings in 2021 we won
the rj
best pizza best pasta best happy hour
best patio
we also wanted in 21 and 20.
we get a lot of tourists and that's why
i was so particular about keeping the
recipes the same because
there's not a week goes by somebody
doesn't come in here and say to me hey i
was in brooklyn last week on avenue j i
had a pizza there man and yours is
exactly like it happy hours from two to
six monday to friday now if you come in
from two to four
every pizza in the restaurant is half
price
every bottle of wine is half price
in addition to that
we have uh eggplant percents which are
normally 14. or seven dollars caesar
salad which is normally 14 is seven
dollars
uh we have all uh wines by the glass
uh beers bottle beers regular beers uh
everything's half price from four to six
everything else is is also half price so
uh if you like happy hour and you're not
coming to doms you're missing out thank
you to dom demarco's pizzeria and bar
for sponsoring that segment open seven
days a week in summerlin for more you
can call
702-570-7000 or visit domdemarcos.com
don't forget those happy hour discounts
every weekday from 2 to 6 p.m